the idea of a star architect may have
actually began with Phillip Johnson
Johnson died in 2005 but we still live
in the shadows of his skyscrapers and
people still visit his infamous home the
Glass House which is now a landmark a
new biography the man in the Glass House
looks at the life of the controversial
architect who was both loved and loathed
in his lifetime with his owl shaped
eyeglasses architect Phillip Johnson was
easily noticed and he enjoys the
attention he had a Barnum esque flair
for publicity he's okay after Frank
Lloyd Wright no American architect was
more famous than Phillip Johnson was
only one reason for my whole life and
that's art and nothing else counts
nothing else gives me pleasure nothing
else gives me satisfaction for his
generation he was the most prominent
American architect he was the first
winner of the Pritzker Prize the Nobel
for architecture in his new biography
the man in the glass house Marc Lam
sturdy constructs the architect who
designed the New York state theater at
Lincoln Center the Amon Carter Museum in
Fort Worth and the Crystal Cathedral in
California and whose buildings help
define the skylines of Houston Boston
Pittsburgh and New York almost every
major American city has a Philip Johnson
some of them are wonderful and some of
them are not super great but they are
but they are ubiquitous Johnson was the
founding architectural curator at the
Museum of Modern Art but in the 1930s as
Hitler was rising in Germany he suddenly
left and he threw away his career as a
curator to try and become this fascist
politician
it's a terrible moment in his history
Johnson's former secretary told the FBI
he wanted to be Hitler in the United
States how long was his involvement in
this it was quite long roughly a decade
where he's deeply invested
in these fascist political ideas by the
end of World War two Johnson had a
change of heart
and he designs a synagogue for free and
he even goes on to build a nuclear
reactor in Israel and befriend Shimon
Peres but the depth of Johnson's fascist
period is the revelation of Lamb stirs
will ever mark did find out that it was
a little more extensive and a little
longer lasting than people had thought
yep and it's important to know that I
mean Paul Goldberger
former architecture critic of The New
Yorker and the New York Times
now chairs the Advisory Council for the
Glass House the radically simple home
Johnson built for himself in New Canaan
Connecticut in 1949 this house was an
attraction almost immediately
yes sort of combination of attraction
and scandal I suppose and I think he
probably liked both sides of it as
critic for the New York Times did you
like everything he did no I did not like
everything he did I found almost
everything he did to be worth taking
seriously however he was simultaneously
I think the elder statesman and the bad
boy of American architecture so he would
do things that would shock people yeah
but he would always do it with a serious
enough edge so you couldn't dismiss it
as nothing but a trick or a joke or what
have you
the architect abounded in contradictions
mark'll Amster writes he was a gay man
with a fascist history living in a glass
house and he liked nothing better than
to throw stones and what point does he
become a celebrity architect it's in the
70s that he becomes a real cultural
presence he's on the cover of Time
magazine holding his plans for the AT&T
building in New York with its
Chippendale grandfather clock top so he
has become the public face of American
architecture much to the chagrin of many
American architects why they disdained
him he liked to proclaim that I am a
[ __ ] and he quite cynically claimed
that he would build for anyone
who would pay in the 90s Johnson began
building for Donald Trump the Trump
International Hotel in New York's
Columbus Circle was one of his projects
New York Times critic famously called it
a solid gold ingot standing on end but
Johnson and and and Trump were made for
each other
really because they were both masters of
branding but their relationship was
bound to fail because Johnson in the end
considered Trump of Vulgarian and Trump
considered Johnson a prima donna and
maybe they were both right good man
Janssen what you find the architect was
still going to the office at 92 when CBS
caught up with him in 1999 I've got to
get certain psych architectural artistic
sculptural ideas across and got it
working out in my mind and get them
built that's all I got to do and if
death made death occurs any time a
modest exercise regime helped keep it at
bay until he was 98 when Phillip Johnson
died here in his Glass House Phillip
Johnson probably lived his life on that
precept of Oscar Wilde who once said you
know the only thing in life worse than
being talked about is not being talked
about
he wanted to be talked about and still
is and still is exactly yeah yeah we
still are and there's so many
contradictions in Phillip Johnson I
think that's the best way to put it
based on what this book seems to say
because you called him a fascist he was
essentially trying to create a Nazi
Party in America in and-and-and went off
to do it himself in the in the 30s and
into the 40s but what's interesting is
so many prominent Jews in in this city
ended up forgiving him for that and
became you know friends vis